[Music]
a long lockdown in uganda
is helping to make covert case numbers
fall but livelihoods are suffering
one in five ugandans have lost their
jobs during the pandemic
to help the government handed out flour
and beans during the first lockdown last
year
now authorities have gone digital they
are using mobile phones to provide cash
payments to those struggling
it's a novel approach in east africa
i'm ben fazel and welcome uganda is in a
precarious situation
case numbers are easing but shortages of
oxygen and vaccines could see a sudden
turn for the worse
intensive care units are still in high
demand we'll talk to someone on the
ground in a moment
first dw's julius mulgamboy reports
grace musimami is a carved-19 survivor
every day he performs breathing
exercises
as his doctors told him he must do
a month ago he was discharged from one
of uganda's public hospitals
they have been overwhelmed by the demand
for oxygen
for coronavirus patients
the oxygen cylinders are basically
shared by many people so you'll get a
cylinder it has 30 percent oxygen
or 50 percent oxygen it's been used by
other people
and probably they've died or they've
been discharged
musamami saw other patients die as they
waited in vain for oxygen
two weeks after he was discharged one of
his close friends
died at another public hospital
after one hour i could not talk to him i
called the whole evening the whole night
in the morning only to reach the
facility
and i was told oh peter that one he
passed on last night
uganda first confirmed akavid-19 death
at the end
of july last year
but case numbers have spiraled recently
the highest number of deaths in a month
were recorded in june
the government wants to vaccinate its
people but has been having trouble
getting enough doses
we have had slightly over a million
doses
into the country and yet we have a
population of over 22 million people
to vaccinate we have made orders but we
are still
on standby so it's a
scarcity of the vaccines that is letting
letting us down
authorities introduced a six-week
partial lockdown
in june but with the more transmissible
delta variant spreading in the country
and last month's steep increase in
infections
grace musi mummy fears that not many
will be as lucky as he was
charles war is senior adviser for access
to finance at the royal danish embassy
in kampala
just how bad are the shortages of oxygen
and vaccines
yeah the second wave really hit us they
hit the health sector
and we had very many cases being admit
being admitted to hospitals but what
really
happened was that the install capacity
for
oxygen in the hospital was far
outstretched
by almost three times what was installed
both in the public and private sector so
it
saw people who really need oxygen and
they can't get it
however on the north the pub the private
sector came in particularly the industry
the the the oxygen manufacturers
stepped in their production capacities
and we had even publix
other entities donating oxygen to these
hospitals at no cost to sort of
alleviate the situation
but as we speak now this destruction is
escalating
as we see more reduction in admissions
so covert is obviously impacting
people's lives and
livelihoods a report you were part of
revealed two-thirds of respondents in
uganda and kenya
experienced income shocks due to the
crisis can you tell us more
yes the long term the lockdown was
really severe
and what we observed in this uh we used
to
we just had you could hear the people
saying i've lost jobs
i've lost my job my business is closing
out because of the
severe lockdown measures that were
instituted by
the government by then and for us in
uganda and then following kenya
it was it was very strict the total
country was
these two countries were really locked
down and people had survived for
instance the service sector was
totally closed and no one could move in
uganda for instance the agricultural
sector was working
but they found supply chains warily
cut off when you look at the industry
the manufacturers were allowed to work
but we wanted to understand how do
households
cope with this severe unpleasant time of
locking down their businesses
and that's how we did that family study
and we before
we wanted to put numbers to some of
these things that we are hearing around
so that it can inform and the planning
planning ahead because we know coffee is
going to be with us
here but people's life must continue
what about people in real dire
situations though what's what's being
done to support the poor
in uganda considering such a long
lockdown no public transportation
little work going around out of the 8
million
people who are recognized by who are
really
known to be poor about 510 000
have given cash transfer and i want to
upload
the office of the prime minister for
this for this
initiative this data is then uploaded is
taken to the minister of the office of
the prime minister
is uploaded into the into the system and
money is sent to the phones directly of
those beneficiaries
so it's just from the telcos to the
phone directly
and for me i think this is one of the
innovations that has come out of this
covet pandemic
charles was speaking to me earlier there
the author of that study on the
economic impact of covet 19 on uganda
and kenya
it found more than two-thirds of
households have experienced
income shocks and worsened food security
let's hope those digital payments get
through to those hit hardest and that
more supplies of oxygen and vaccine
become available for ugandans
a little look at some of the other
developments around the world
haiti has received its first shipment of
covert vaccines
half a million doses donated by the us
government
they were distributed through the kovac
sharing scheme for poorer countries
only 22 percent of haitians say they'll
accept the [ __ ]
south korea recorded its second highest
daily coronavirus
tally on thursday 1600 new cases
infections are spreading beyond the
heart hit capital where officials have
enforced the country's toughest social
distancing restrictions
the government is urging citizens to
cancel their plans and stay home
iraqis have protested outside a burnt
down covert ward
calling for justice at least 60 people
died
the blaze at al hussein hospital in the
city of nazarea on monday evening was
the second such deadly fire in iraq
in the past few months both were blamed
on the explosion of badly stored oxygen
bottles
sydney is reporting a slowdown in new
covert cases as residents enjoy their
third week of lockdown
australia's largest city is trying to
suppress the highly contagious delta
variant
total infections across the harbour city
stand and over 900
two deaths have been reported the first
for the country this year
and growing coronavirus clusters have
sparked the neighboring state of
victoria to go into lockdown for five
days
now an interesting question on variants
and strains that one of our viewers sent
to dw science correspondent derek
williams
please explain the difference between a
new strain and a new variant
this is tough to do since even
virologists
seem to view the differences as fairly
fluid but
but let's start by maybe going over some
of the other
biology basics that you've you've
probably
learned this year already um first is
that although
it's technically not considered alive
a virus evolves constantly as it
replicates just like living things do
its genetic code changes because
mistakes happen
as the code is copied by a living
cell that gives rise to what are
commonly known
as mutants um now for complicated
biological reasons
not every mutation leads to actual
physical changes in a viruses structure
but but when it does you can begin
thinking of that
mutant as a variant
now a variant is generally considered a
strain
when it's wandered even farther down
that road and
acquired characteristics and and
behaviors
based on its new structure that clearly
distinguish it
from other earlier forms so
you could say that although all strains
are variants
not all variants are strains let's maybe
make
a comparison from the macro world um
we've been
genetically engineering dogs for
thousands of years through selective
breeding
and it's pretty astounding how how
different they can look but dogs
all share common characteristics
that allow you to instantly identify an
animal
as a dog whether it's a chihuahua or a
newfoundland
the different breeds can be viewed as
variants
on the canine genome but go far enough
back and and split off another
evolutionary branch
and you end up with the modern wolf
which
has a common ancestor but some distinct
characteristics and behaviors that allow
us
to instantly identify it as a wolf
so if they were viruses then breeds of
dogs
would be variants while dogs and wolves
would be strains now i'm the first to
admit that the analogy is
imperfect but maybe it makes the terms a
little easier to grasp